you
hello everyone welcome to this quiz
today on data science
to request you to bear with us as we
wait for a few minutes for other people
to join feel free to introduce yourself
in the comments section while we wait
i'm just going to wait for a few minutes
for the people to join
also just as a
fyi
to take part in the quiz it is highly
recommended to use your mobile phone and
visit the website www.menti.com
and use the code 2783-1695
the code is visible on the screen you
can see it on the stream you can also
use a different tab on your laptop
browser for example to take part in the
quiz but a live stream will be
displaying the results as the quiz goes
on
so it's highly recommended and
beneficial to have both screens visible
at the same time that's why it's easier
to take part in the quiz using the
mobile phone so once you open the link
www.menti.com
use the code
27831695 which is shown on the screen
and wait for the quiz to start and be
ready to answer the questions
the quicker you answer the more points
you get okay so think past and click
faster
okay so while we wait for other people
to join
allow me to introduce our viewers to the
world of data science
okay so what is data science
data science is the field of study that
deals with modern scientific knowledge
statistical methods and algorithms to
derive insights from vast volume of data
a myriad of companies use data science
generating data every single minute
there is a need to make sense of this
data and use it for our own benefit in
the long run
even when it comes to companies that use
data science new sigma fractal fidelity
intel amazon and many other companies
connect their dots and use data science
in their ventures
just about every business out there
directly or indirectly uses data science
to help govern their business and help
them grow and compete in the business
world
when it comes to the need for data
science
we use the data science models to find
unseen patterns within the data
you can use it to analyze and draw
insight from our data while solving
business problems and making crisp
decisions
there is a particular life cycle
attached to the data science the data
science is the life cycle where we start
with the data discovery then we go
through data preparation exploratory
data analysis data modeling interpret
the results and back to data discovery
we'll not go to too much details right
now since this is just an introduction
for people who are unaware of data
science
what we will go through is the data
science applications
when it comes to applications the first
one is internet search
this is something that we all use every
day
it's the search engines like google and
bing they all use data science to
deliver accurate results based on search
parameters which are provided by the
users
secondly voice assistance
voice resistance analyzes the voice
coming in and connecting with whatever
patterns they need to activate you can
ask you to turn your lights on in the
living room control music switch on our
vehicles etc the possibilities are
endless
however the biggest field growing right
now in the data science field is
healthcare
we analyze health data from a smart
watch spread across the world ways to
counter these diseases and monitor daily
exercise results among other things we
identify cancer versus non-cancer so we
know who to prioritize and get them in
for surgery but other people might not
need that immediate care and even
identify problems somebody might have
with their health long before they even
happen
it's a very neat thing to do which is
instead of waiting until you have a
heart attack you know months ahead of
time that you will develop odd
conditions
the next would be logistics
logistics is basically how one goes from
point a to point b
if you ever look at some of the major
distributors they pre-ship things based
on what the guest people are going to
need this way you get your stuff right
in the mailbox the day after you order
it
similarly ecommerce is huge in data
science because you have to know what
kind of marketing we're going to put out
who we are selling to what's our target
audience etc
finally we also have robotics reporters
is one of the more fun ones when you're
coming into the future
it's all the more essential in
automating the different tasks that we
have
self-driving cars to manufacturing lines
to maybe even a self-robotic chef in the
kitchen data science has its fingers all
over the place when it comes to the
future of robotics
that's all we need to know about data
science from a layman's perspective
right now
and we can start with the quiz
so just a reminder
to take part in the quiz please visit
our website www.menti.com
and use the code
27831695 which is shown at top of the
screen right now
like i mentioned before do try to visit
this using your mobile phone so you can
take care of the results which are being
shown on the stream
this will help you stay in touch with
the standings since the top three
winners will be receiving amazon
vouchers from simply learn
faster answers equal higher points so
fire away as soon as you have a hunch
it's just wait for a minute or two to
get more people to join since they have
to visit the url and need support then
we can start the quiz
okay see around 25 people have joined
will be needing a few more
you can use this time to introduce
yourself in the comments
let us know what you do if you're a
student if you're a working professional
have a chat in the comments i'm pretty
sure people are more than willing to
communicate with it
i think have enough people
okay
because we have enough people to take
part in the quiz so let's get started
with the first question
here comes question number one
what is the function in python to
compute the summary statistics for each
numerical column in a data frame
is it option a head
is it option b summary
is it option c describe
or option d stats
the function in python to compute the
summary statistics for each numerical
column in a data frame
once again guys answers provided in the
youtube
comments will not be considered so
please visit the url and input the code
to take part the top three winners will
be receiving amazon vouchers just to
remind them
okay so you see majority okay 11 people
were able to answer correctly which is
the describe function so the python's
described function is to display summary
statistics such as mean standard
deviation minimum and maximum values
percentiles etc for each numerical
column in a data frame it can provide
separate values
for example if the data frame is df then
you can write df.described to print out
the summary statistics
pretty simple explanation
similarly we have a lot of people answer
the question correctly
so we have the first
10 people who have made their way in the
leaderboard remember guys
these are the people who answer the
quick list so we will get a hunch
just answer okay the faster you answer
the more points you get
moving on to question number two
but the magnitude of one variable
decreases with an increase in another
variable
what kind of correlation do they have
is it a perfect correlation
does it be no correlation
does it see positive correlation or d
negative correlation
the magnitude of one value is decreasing
while the other is increasing and vice
versa what kind of correlation do they
possess
10 more seconds to give you answers
okay by the majority of people have
given already 25 people
let's see how many were able to get it
correct
okay more than half option yeah so the
correct answer is negative correlation
so in statistics and data science a
negative correlation is a relationship
between two variables in which one
variable increases as the other
decreases and vice versa
for example if the speed of the car
increases the time taken to reach the
destination will decrease
pretty straight forward
okay so
[Music]
we can see
the people who answered quickly okay we
have current still at the top santiago
second
approach yet we have a long way to go so
answer quickly and you'll be one of the
top three winners moving on to question
number three
one dimensional array defined in pandas
that can be used to store any data type
is called dash
is it a series is it a dictionary
is it an nd array or a list
one dimensional array defined in padders
that can be used to store any data type
you can see the code on top of the
screen to join
few more seconds
okay
almost
majority got the answer correct which is
a series the series is a one dimensional
labeled array that can pull data for any
data type basically integer string
boolean
everything the access labels are called
the indexes so the correct answer here
is option a which is a series i think
we'll have a change in the leaderboard
with sanjay dropping down
yes
dropping down to seven okay so we have
jatin who has taken up third position
and is on route to getting his amazon
voucher let's move on to question number
four
which of the following statements is
correct about random forest algorithm
is a random forest are difficult to
interpret but often very accurate
is it b they're easy to interpret but
often very accurate is it see that
difficult to interpret and not even
accurate or is it d none of the above
read the options carefully and make sure
you choose the answer which is correct
about the random forest algorithm
you have 10 more
seconds so this is the question where a
lot of people are taking time to answer
okay majority will answer correctly
which is random forests are difficult to
interpret but they are very accurate so
they have multiple decision trees and
merges them together to get a more
accurate and a stable result they are
often difficult to interpret because of
these multiple trees that were fitting
but they can be very accurate for a long
range of problems
similar to last question
second and third position are not able
to answer correctly which will most
likely push them down
and they did with raghav and jc taking
the second and third spot
as we want to question number five
which of the following methods do we use
to find the best fit line for data in
linear regression
is it a maximum likelihood
is it b least square error
is it c logarithmic loss
or d both a and b
which are the following methods do we
use to find the best fit line for data
in linear regression
okay time's up
okay the
i think our less than 50 are able to
give the correct answer which is least
square error so the linear regression
algorithm uses the sum of squared errors
or residuals basically to get the best
pit line for a model now least square is
used because it is the smallest sum of
squares of errors
then it gives us the best fit line
okay
third position jc was not able to answer
which process him to sixth position and
we have
new top three altogether okay let's move
on to question number six
the find s algorithm ignores which
parameters
is it option a the positive parameters
option b the negative parameters
which is ignores both positive and
negative parameters or d it takes
everything into consideration and does
not ignore anything straight away
the find s algorithm ignores which
parameter
t more seconds for you to answer
time is up 24 people have answered this
yeah 14 people answered the right answer
which is negative
the finest algorithm starts from the
most specific hypothesis and generalizes
it by considering only positive examples
it ignores negative
examples as long as the hypothesis space
contains a hypothesis that describes the
true target concept and the training
data contains no errors
ignoring negative examples does not
cause any problem to the accuracy of the
model
okay majority were able to answer in the
top 10 except gc which is only going to
push them down further but sandhya being
the fastest one to answer this question
okay let's move on question number seven
which of the following statements is
false
is it a subsetting can be used to select
and exclude variables and observations
is it b raw data should be processed
multiple times
if you see merging concerns combining
data sets to produce results
or is it d none of the above
read the options very carefully
considering just a few more calls
10 more seconds
for those who haven't joined the quiz
yet but are on the youtube screen follow
the url and the code mentioned on top of
the screen to take part in the quiz the
top three winners are going to receive
amazon vouchers from simply learn
so let's start out with
okay the correct answer is option b
which is raw data should be processed
multiple times
technically it should not considering it
is the whole statement the raw data may
only need to be processed once data
processing starts with data in its raw
form and converts it into a more
readable format
this can be graphs documents sheets etc
giving it the form and context necessary
to be interpreted by computers and
utilized by employees throughout an
organization
you see around four people not able to
answer in the top 10
i highly recommend people who are not a
part of the top 10 right now to answer
quickly and get into the leaderboard
because a lot of the questions are being
missed by the people who already are a
part of the leaderboard
okay so let's move on to question number
eight
which is what does the k stand for in
the k-mean algorithm
is it option a number of clusters
is it b number of data
you should see the number of trees per
day
number of iterations
what is the k stands for in the k-mean
algorithm
15 more seconds
five more seconds to give your
answer okay
so the correct answer is
pretty
good answer is obviously number of
clusters where a cluster refers to a
collection of data points aggregated
together because of certain similarities
you define a target number k which
refers to the number of centroids you
need in the data set
are centered in the imaginary or real
location representing the center of the
cluster
this way every data point is allocated
to each of the clusters by reducing the
in cluster sum of squares
everyone was able to answer the question
correctly
but karan has taken raghav's first
position just because he was able to
answer quickly
see
speed is helpful let's move on to
question number nine and let's see
people make use of that speed while
answering so the question number nine is
which one of the following statements is
true for a decision tree
visit option a decision trees are only
suitable for the classification problem
statement
is it be that the entropy of a node
decreases as we go down the decision
tree
does it see entropy determines purity
or d decision tree can only be used for
numeric value and continuous attributes
once again
this the question is which are the
following statements is true for a
decision tree
real options careful
two more seconds
and
we are up
okay 11 people answer greatly a lot of
people answer the first option
second option entropy of a node
decreases as we go down the decision
tree
so the entropy is an information theory
metric that measures the impurity or
uncertainty in a group of observations
which directly eliminates a third option
which is entropy determines purity it's
supposed to determine impurity it
determines how a decision tree chooses
to split data and helps determine the
impurity of a node as we go down the
decision tree
that would be decreasing
so we're done at nine questions so far
let's see the leaderboard it's pretty
fifty fifty right now in the top ten
with
two people of the question it's a jumble
between the top three with raghav and
current exchanging blows for the top
position
okay
let's move on to question number 10.
how do you choose the right node while
constructing a decision tree
is this is it option a which is an
attribute having high entropy
is to be an attribute having high
entropy and information gain
is it see an attribute having the lowest
information gain or d
an attribute having the highest
information gain period
a lot of people answers very quickly
before 10 seconds came up on the counter
it would be fairly easy i'm hoping a lot
of people answer this correctly then
considering the speed with which we
received answers for this question
or are we in for a shock let's see
it's pretty split between option d and d
the correct option would be an attribute
having the highest information game
so we can define the information gain as
a measure of how much information a
feature provides about a class
information again helps to determine the
order of attributes in the nodes of a
decision tree the main node is referred
to as the parent node whereas the sub
nodes are known as the child nodes
we can use information gain to determine
how good the splitting of notes in and
decision tree is and can help us
determine the quality of splitting
the way people are answered i was
thinking okay this is
probably the first time saying where the
top five answered correctly
but not the
bottom five which only widens the gap
between both halves of the top 10
leaderboard
just a quick reminder the top three
scorers at the end of the quiz do not
close your laptop close your phones or
anything just take a screenshot and send
it to youtube contest at simplylearn.net
to receive your amazon voucher this is
just something for our own verification
that not anybody is sending the entries
okay so take a picture or a screenshot
and send it to youtube contests at
simplylearn.net to receive your amazon
vouchers this is for the top three
scorers at the end of the quiz
for now let's move on to question number
elect
so what distance metrics are suitable
for categorical variables to find the
closest neighbours
is it option a
euclidean distance
is it being manhattan distance is its
the minkowski distance or d
hamming distance
i'm fairly certain people who are
unaware of data science
are really scratching their heads as to
what is going on
three more seconds
is the nuclear distance manhattan
distance then cause the distance or
hamming distance
five more seconds
i think a couple of people missed
answering the question this time
okay majority answered euclidean which
is
not correct answer is hammering distance
which is a metric for comparing two
binary data strings while comparing two
binary springs of equal length hamming
distance is the number of bit positions
in which the two bits are different
the hammer distribution two strings a
and b is denoted by the vector of a and
b
in order to calculate the hammering
distance between the two strings we
perform the xor operation and then count
the total number of ones in the
resultant string
around six people able to answer
correctly
this will probably push current down to
fifth position but one more being
the fastest one to answer this round of
question
okay let's move on to question number 12
as you're almost halfway with our
question tech
what are the terms cli stand for
is it option a command line interface
does it be command command language
interface or c command line intercom
it should be fairly easy i'm guessing
what does the term cli stand for command
line interface command language
interface or command line
15 more seconds
i think a lot of people are answering
very quickly
let's see yeah it's pretty expected
right 22 people answered the third
question which is
come online interface see the cli or
command line interface the text based
user interface used to run programs
manage computer files
interact with another computer etc
the command line interfaces are also
called command line user interfaces
console user interfaces and character
user interfaces some of the reasons why
i did not put those options
in in the question
okay so majority will answer greatly
except sandhya
which
might push her down the leaderboard okay
it did not okay so our top 10 is contact
let's move on
to question number 30.
inference engines work on the principle
of
is it a forward chaining
is it be backward chaining
is it see both a and b which is both
forward chaining and backward chaining
or option d none of the above
what principle do inference engines work
on
okay the correct option is backward
chaining
so the forward chaining is known as
forward deduction or forward reasoning
method when using an inference engine
the fortune is form of reasoning which
start with atomic sentences in the
knowledge base and applies in
differentials in the forward direction
backward chaining is known as backward
reduction or backward reasoning when
using an inference engine
a backward chaining algorithm is form of
reasoning which starts with the goal and
works backward accordingly
so
810 antenna able to answer correctly but
our top 10 still remains unchanged
we're going to move on to question
number 14.
which algorithm of the following gives
us the least memory
is it a depth first search
is it b red first search is it c both
option a and b use the same memory
or is d there cannot be any comparison
between depth first and breadth for
search when comparing the memory
allocation
which of these algorithms uses the least
memory
five more seconds
and everyone has voted with the correct
answer being the majority's choice which
is depth first search
the fps uses a lesser amount of memory
because at a time the path from the node
to a root is only stored in the memory
step unlike bread per search or vfs
which stores the whole tree in it
yeah except for everyone were able to
answer
oh the first top three has been
consistent for a while now let's see if
there is any change for the following
few questions
question number 15
which of the following is false about
correlation and covariance
is option a a zero correlation does not
necessarily imply impedance between
variables
option b is correlation and covariance
values are the same
option c the covariance and correlation
are always the same sign or d
correlation is a standardized version of
covariance
once again reminding the question is
which of the following is false
about correlation and covariance
almost done
time is up
very few people answer the correspond
they are not the same correlation values
values are the same is completely false
the covariance is a statistical term
that refers to a systematic relationship
between two random variables in which a
change in the other reflects a change in
one variable
the value can range from like minus
infinity to plus infinity with a
negative value indicating a negative
relationship and a positive error
getting a positive relationship
in statistics correlation is a measure
that determines the degree to which two
or more random variables move in
sequence
when an equivalent movement of another
variable reciprocates the movement of
one in some way or the other the
variables are said to be correlated
which basically means both of them are
not the same
that's why the correct option is option
number b
okay these three people in the top 10
were able to answer correctly let's see
if we can move up
ravi has moved to the sixth position now
let's see how far he goes
moving on to question number 16
which of the following algorithms in
machine learning is called a lazy
learner
is it option a which is k means
clustering
is it option b which is k nearest
neighbors
is its c nave bias or the decision trees
which are the following algorithms in
machine learning is called the lazy
learning algorithm
it's a complete concept is a completely
different learning method which is the
lazy learning method so the following
algorithms embodies that
10 more seconds to give your answer
okay so time is up
pretty expected k nearest neighbors is
the correct answer but majority of
people were able to answer correctly
for those unaware in machine learning
lazy learning is a learning method in
which the generalization of the training
data is delayed until a query is made to
the system as opposed to eager learning
where the system tries to generalize the
training data even before they start
receiving queries
the best example of this is knn or care
nearest neighbors it basically stores
all of the points then uses the data
when you make a query to it
i think people were not able to answer
very quickly this time
hence the low scores without those
moving up top and current being the
fastest for this question
moving on to question number 17.
which of the following is true about
residuals
is it option a the higher the better
is it option b the lower the better
or is it option c it depends really on
the situation where the higher residual
is better for the model or a lowest rule
is better it's inconclusive and
irrelevant
so which is true about residuals is it
better if it's higher or is it better if
it's low
five more seconds
okay
majority answered correctly which is
option b
the lower the residual is better
the residuals exist in a statistical or
machine learning model the differences
between observed and predicted values of
data there are diagnostic measure used
when accessing the quality of a model
they're also known as errors so
by extension the lower the residual the
lower the error and more accurate the
predictions in your regression system
are
so the lower industrials means highly
accurate model
we might see a shuffle this time
considering four of the top five are not
able to answer correctly but you know
the gap is too big although is making
his way up top
while i implore others
to take these last few sets of questions
seriously because we are running towards
the end and this is the 18th question
which is which of the following is a
widely used and effective machine
learning algorithm based on the idea of
bagging
option a decision tree
that option b support vector machine is
it observable option c which is
regression or option d random forest
which one of these is based on the idea
of bagging and everyone quoted very
quickly at this time okay we did we have
to wait for the counter okay now 13
people answer the correct question which
is random forest
see it builds an ensemble of decision
trees mostly with the bagging method
it's also known as bootstrap aggregation
it's an ensemble learning method that is
commonly used to reduce variance within
a noisy data set
pretty
untouched leaderboard except one
position
so we're going to move on to question
number 19.
which of the following machine learning
techniques helps in detecting the
outliers in data
is it option a
anomaly detection
option b clustering
option c classification
or option d none of the upper
which of them techniques help in
detecting the outliers in data
providing very quickly for the past last
few questions okay the opt-in correct
option is a anomaly detection which is
any process that finds the outliers of a
data set
basically which are the items that do
not belong in the dataset okay these
anomalies might point to unusual network
traffic and cover a sensor on the fridge
or simply identify data for cleaning
before the analysis starts
so you're not going to see a lot of
change in the leaderboard now
and we are not seems raghav jatin and
prachi
on their way to receive the vouchers for
being one of our top three winner
there's still time to change with
question number 20 which is which of the
following statement is true about the
base
classifier the talking a base classifier
works on the base theorem of probability
is it b base classifies an unsupervised
learning algorithm
is it c that the classifier is also
known as the maximum empirical
classifier or d
it assumes the independence between
independent variables
quite a handful and
which of the politicians is true about
the base classifier
this is the question where not everyone
was able to answer quickly and we could
have jumped the timer
so times up and
least number of people give the correct
answer which is option b
the base classifier is an unsupervised
learning algorithm
the base
classifier internally uses the concept
of base theorem protect the precision
for unseen data points it describes the
probability of occurrence of an event
related to any condition
it is also considered for the case of
conditional probability
okay no one in the top 10 is able to
answer that question correctly
so we're going to move on to question
number 21.
inappropriate selection of learning rate
value in gradient descent gives rise to
what
is a local minimum is it b oscillations
is it c slow convergence or d all of the
above
inappropriate selection of learning rate
value in gradient descent gives rise to
which phenomenon
ten more seconds
one and time is up
yeah correct all of these phenomenon can
be seen see the learning rate decides
how fast or slow or optimizer is able to
achieve the global minimum so by
choosing an inappropriate value of
learning rate we may not reach the
global minimum but instead be stuck at a
local minimum oscillate around the
minimum and become the cause of which
convergence time increases so the
current option is the all of the upper
majority were able to answer correctly
so i'm not assuming a lot of change in
the board but
let's see
now it seems thomas only moved up to
position number five
still
the top three are still untouched let's
move on to the next question
which is which of the following
statements is false about rich and lasso
regression
is it option c that these are types of
regularization methods to solve the
overfitting problem
is it option b
which says lasso regression is a type of
regularization method
the c ridge regression shrinks the
coefficient to a lower value
or d
it lowers some coefficients to a zero
value
once again which of the foreign
statements is false
about the bridge and lasso regression
20 more seconds to give your answers
just a reminder the people who are in
the top three positions
please send a screenshot or a picture of
your position on the quiz after the base
ends where it clearly states you are in
the first place second place or third
place etc and send us the screenshot to
youtube contest at simplylearn.net to
receive your amazon voucher meanwhile 9
people answer the question correctly
which is option d
bridge regression never drops any
feature instead it shrinks the
coefficients however lasso regression
drops some features by making the
coefficient of that feature zero
therefore the latter is used as a
feature selection technique
okay there might be a shuffle in places
right now
no still
the gap between raghav and the rest of
the crew is
seems to be too big to
breach right now but the final three
questions are here which is 23
which of the following is the revision
control system
this is option a
sign
we should option b which is git
or option c number by
expected lot more answers by this time
to be honest
which of the following is a revision
control system
i get a number
five more seconds
and 16 people answered correctly which
is
git
git is a software for tracking changes
in any set of files usually used for
coordinating work among programmers
collaboratively developing source code
this happens during software development
process cycle
the goals include speed data integrity
and support for distributed non-linear
workflows which makes the job of sub
developers that more helpful
everyone answer the question except
current in the top 10 prachi being the
fastest with once again no change in the
leaderboard final two questions
this is your time to shine for people in
the top five
so how do we perform bayesian
classification when some features are
missing
so option a we integrate the posterior's
probabilities over the missing features
is it option b we ignore the missing
features
is it see we assume the missing values
as the mean of all values
or option d
we drop the features completely
20 more seconds to give the answer
how do we perform bayesian
classification when some of the features
are missing
a handful of people have not answered
this one
actually
it's weird
but the ones who did majority of them
got it right which is option a we
integrate the posterior's probabilities
and some features are missing while
performing basic classification we don't
use general methods of handling missing
values we integrate the positive
probabilities for better predictions so
option a is correct in this case
okay there has been a bit of distinction
comes to the time taken to answer
still the same three people at the top
let's see if something happens in the
final question
question number 25
which of the following step is performed
by the data scientist after acquiring
the data
is it a data replication
is it b data cleansing
is it c data integration
or d all of the mentioned which of the
following step is performed by the data
scientist immediately after acquiring
the data
replication cleansing integration
or all of the above
10 more seconds
to answer the final question of today's
quiz
time is up
the correct answer being data cleansing
so data cleansing or data cleaning data
scrubbing is the process of detecting
and correcting corrupt or inaccurate
records from a database table or record
set and is generally performed by data
scientists after acquiring the data
immediately
which is the final question of this quiz
let's see if there is any change
no it seems the top three positions are
consistent with rather getting the first
position and japan and prachi getting
the second answer position in the swiss
respectively congratulations to all
three of you please send a screenshot of
your screen or a picture to youtube
contest at simplylearn.net to get your
amazon vouchers we thank everyone else
for taking part in this quiz and for the
people who have not taken part in the
quiz but have been following the results
on the youtube stream we will keep
having these quizzes with different
topics and different technologies so be
sure to subscribe to our channel and
follow our community post to be alerted
a day before these quizzes are held so
you are not late and get your chance to
win an amazon voucher
thank you so much for taking part today
for spending your time stay safe
you